the cry is a very distressed one very
high-pitched one and no effort console
seems to attempts to help the baby one
baby every half an hour in the United
States is born addicted to drugs we have
had cases where the mother admits that I
just shot up heroin in the parking lot
before I came in to deliver my baby on
these wards milk and methadone go hand
in hand death is one of the outcomes you
you may die from it and certainly babies
would be more vulnerable to death and
than adults
a place where mothers are racked with
guilt
I mean you don't have one like your kid
to go through that we've come to Indiana
a state witnessing an epidemic of drug
abuse it's a lot of heroin use down here
a lot of other drugs as well but Aaron
was pretty bad in the neighborhood where
painkillers are so strong that when
supplies run out there is only one
alternative I mean I made money every
day just to have it we asked what's
causing this epidemic and who's to blame
and question what the long-term genetic
effects might be for the youngest
victims of them all worse than all of
that is that these imprints can become
heritable can be passed down from one
generation to the next
we had no idea that this was possible
but now we do
[Music]
this is Elijah he's only six weeks old
but he's already had a lifetime of pain
his mother was addicted to strong
painkillers and throughout her whole
pregnancy was taking the heroin
substitute methadone to wean herself off
it meant that when her son was born he
had crippling withdrawals from the drug
he'd become dependent on in the womb in
a decade the number of babies in this
situation hasn't just crept up its
quadrupled the babies generally within
12 to 24 hours have significant symptoms
of withdrawal from those narcotics
crying vomiting it's a very very painful
agitating for you know process for them
and the reality is we have to give them
that narcotic back and slowly wean them
off
[Music]
Elijah's mum Jessica is only 27 but
she's had three children and she has
four stepchildren this isn't the first
child she's had that suffered drug
withdrawal it happened with her last
baby too
[Music]
after two epidurals and three spinal
taps you're gonna have a hurt back I was
getting prescriptions here and there and
I noticed that they helped and not by if
I ran out I mean I was getting my own
and that's kind of just how it led to
all of this so taking them you know I
just I was able to get things done that
I wanted to do and I didn't have pain
and I could be supermom I guess the
arrow and I mean I had I it went from
just taking them on the weekends to
really actually needing them you know
starting to need them everyday because
you wake up feeling sick and once you
start noticing that and then it's just a
day-to-day thing as you know I gotta
have a few just so I don't feel sick or
I gotta have you know even if it's just
one to wake up to in the morning just so
I'm not feeling my
I think there's a lot of guilt I think
there's a lot of anxiety that they have
provoked this on their baby we have had
cases where the mother admits that I
just shot up heroin in the parking lot
before I came in to deliver my baby they
deliver the baby and try to get her but
within 24 hours she signs herself out or
she just disappears
in Indiana addiction rates for heroin
have soared hospital figures show
there's a heroin related overdose every
single day a few years ago meth was all
the rage around here and in fact across
the United States but times have changed
the drug of choice here in Indiana
became the humble painkiller a very
strong one from the opiate family the
same family as heroin but as supplies
run low and doctors forced to prescribe
less many people are going back not to
meth but to heroin
fueling one of the biggest epidemics the
United States has ever seen
we've stopped by the roadside in one of
the most dangerous neighborhoods in
Indianapolis it's well known for drugs
and gun crime a 27 year old woman the
police have arrested is suspected to
have just been injecting heroin police
have found used needles in her bag we're
told that the nature of crime here is
beginning to change as the appetite for
painkillers and heroin increases once
again I can tell you this that our
number-one robberies like business
robberies now when I started it was
convenience stores then it moved into
some maybe some of the fast food places
and now it's a lot of it recently the
last six months it's been the pharmacies
and spent drugs they were just some
painkillers for my combat injury I never
knew they were so addictive more people
abuse prescription drugs like cocaine
heroin hallucinogens and inhalants
combined this is the new weapon against
the painkillers ads like this one are
all over the TV in Indiana and every 25
minutes someone dies from a prescription
drug overdose get the facts
visit bitter pill
[Music]
I think throughout our entire city what
we're really seeing is a big spike in
opiates of all kind the addiction
counselors have never been busier and
Eric Davis former addict himself runs
four of the biggest rehab centers in
Indianapolis I think here in the United
States you know it's we try to take a
pill for everything you know it's like
oh we've got a pill for that
the problem with opiates is that they
they work so well you know they do their
job so well that people start taking
them and they don't realize that they're
basically sighted their soul over to
these things I mean once they have a
hold of you there's you can't get off of
them pain-free
according to the Center for Disease
Control and Prevention 259 million
prescriptions for powerful painkillers
were written in 2014 that's enough for
every American adult to have their own
bottle of pills a 400% increase in
opiate prescription rates was was the
was the the beginning of this epidemic
and you might ask how that occurred and
that occurred because a sort of wha war
on pain was perpetrated upon us it
seemed to come from the public but in
fact it was funded by Big Pharma so what
could the long-term effects be for
babies in drug withdrawal the answer
could come from alarming scientific data
which suggests that the damage done to
babies in the womb could imprint on
their very DNA affecting them and
possibly their children to worse than
all of that is that these imprints can
become heritable can be passed down from
one generation to the next we had no
idea that this was possible but now we
do what we don't know is specifically
whether opiates and exposures that
babies are undergoing are causing this
I mean I hope it won't affect him and
he's you know a little bit older and
sometimes when my one-year-old cries or
does certain things I always think I I
think back to her withdrawing and I'm
like well maybe that's you know maybe
that's a reason why she does certain
things I guess you'd say
maybe cries a certain way or it gets
real tense sometimes and I always think
that I mean I wouldn't want that to
happen do the daily mix of milk and
morphine is an unlikely joke but it's
all doctors can do and no one knows how
this will affect him in the future
[Music]
you don't know what could happen things
could go from good to bad you know in
the blink of an eye so I feel especially
bad for the for the victims of our
liberal use of opiate prescriptions
because we've basically set them up they
had they weren't had they not been
exposed to opiates this would not have
happened to them this is something
Elijah will never remember but if the
fears of scientists are realized this
episode in his life is something his
body his very genetic makeup may never
be able to forget McMartin Sky News
Indiana
[Music]
you